you
[Music]
the next talk is going to be given by
Professor Timothy Roscoe he's commonly
and fondly referred to as mati I think
he prefers that so I'm just gonna call
him mati mati graduated from the
University of Cambridge he worked on an
operating system called nemesis I
encourage you all to go and read read
about it I think I have known mati since
he was a graduate student ah
after Cambridge he worked in startups he
worked at Sprint he worked at the Intel
research lab I lost track of that after
Intel but he now teaches at the ETH in
in Zurich Barry does his group does
operating systems research hardware
research and so on so forth I think I
was a grad student so thanks very much
for inviting me this talk is gonna be
very different from what Jung's talk so
it's gonna be I need to preface it with
a bunch of disclaimers first thing is
that unlike his talk I'm not going to
show you much in the way of nice numeric
results or indeed results this is very
much work in progress and at the moment
we're fairly confident that it's going
to work but he doesn't necessarily work
yet okay and you'll see you'll see that
to go through second thing is that I am
NOT a machine learning or an AI person I
pointed this out to John do and he you
know did not rescind my invitation as a
result of this but I'm very much sort of
systems systems software person as
Charlie says operating systems and
networking so this is very much from
that sort of perspective someone who
doesn't necessarily work much in machine
learning has some friends who do but at
the same time machine learning is one of
the key sort of drivers behind some
motivates kind of work I'm going to talk
about here
the third thing I'm going to do is is
say that you know it's trendy so they'll
spend about almost exactly half of my
career post-graduation in industry but
I'm going to talk about this work very
much from the perspective of an academic
okay which is well I
an hour but this is a talk specifically
about what it means to be an academic
doing systems research right now right
this is a very interesting time to be
doing systems research because a whole
load of things are changing a particular
there's some very interesting changes
with workloads machine learning
partly enabled as people have said by
these you know the advent of very high
performance computing has itself then
factored back and changed how people are
thinking about the computing platforms
that they build all right and that you
know there are other drivers for that as
well you know mobile phones and things
have really internally now look very
very different to the way that a PC used
to look for instance in terms of the
number of processors the kinds of
processors how they're connected up
inside the phone or in some basis inside
the SOC inside the phone so it's very
interesting time to be doing systems of
operating systems research the workloads
are changing the hardware is changing
the question is what do you do if you
like me or an academic doing research
into system software okay and a
particular the advent of a lot of custom
software very diverse software and also
reconfigurable logic okay at one level
workloads like large-scale machine
learning
big data workloads things like that it's
changing and the question is what do we
do right and I'm going to talk about
what it means for us to do that I'm
going to talk about a computer that
we're building in order to do research
okay and this seems like a strange sort
of thing today I mean it's a great
excuse to build a computer but I'm going
to talk about why we're actually
deciding to build a computer for
ourselves what that means given all this
fancy Hardware out there why are we then
building another piece of hardware okay
that's really what this talk is about so
I'm gonna start with an observation
about what is happening in the hardware
landscape okay
almost all the interesting systems out
there increase out at scale are
increasingly using custom hardware they
using chips that have been designed
specifically for particular workloads or
they using reconfigurable logic in the
form of FPGAs
or both okay there was a time there was
a long period of time which I can
remember the start of and I couldn't
just about remember the end of all right
when Chandu and I were young and
enthusiastic about things computers were
hugely diverse all right there are many
many different kinds of computers and
operating systems out there many people
built their own computers but the
hardware architecture was quite diverse
and so the field of system software
research was sort of navigating this
quite diverse Hardware space okay then a
few things happened the PC came along PC
typically run you know a fairly standard
operating system if you're out in the
commercial world
this was Windows if you're in the
academic space or the hobbyist basis was
Linux and suddenly everything became a
remarkably standardized okay even even
inside phones things looked a little bit
like pcs but with ARM processors almost
all the commodity desktops laptops sort
of appliances were pcs also for IOT
early IOT devices were little pcs
basically and in the data center there
were just clusters of PCs there's
extraordinary standardization horizontal
ization of the market okay
and just recently that has all changed
again it's changed in the phone space
which I'm not going to talk about all
the edge space because custom hardware
is needed to keep the power down or
lower ending all the rest of that kind
of stuff and in the data center space
which is probably where I'll be talking
about most it's changed as well we have
a lot of custom hardware a 6f PJs on
chip accelerators beyond GPUs GPUs I
think maybe one of the first symptoms of
this but now you've got things like you
know Google's cloud TPU widespread
deployment of FPGAs in the cloud data
centers places like Baidu Alibaba
Amazon f1 you can go on to Amazon Web
Services and you could rent a machine
with some big big FPGAs in it download
your bit stream onto those FPGAs and you
know do your blockchain hashing or
whatever it is you want to do on
amazon's cloud and pay them in
accordance for it a lot of people
building custom hardware some of which
makes it to market some of which is
canceled some of which pivots into
something else but projects like the
machine from HP
Oracle's rapid system the spark m7 has
been very interesting database
acceleration calls for big data
Microsoft of course one of the pioneers
in this area of deploying FPGAs and data
centers in the form of the project that
was originally called catapult now as
your smart NIC is one of the
applications for that particular piece
of hardware and so on and so on and so
on okay so this is interesting there's a
lot of stuff going on in the way of you
know custom hardware right that doesn't
look like a PC however that means if
you're a university you're doing system
software research whether it's databases
or operating systems or frameworks for
machine learning or something else you
have a problem which is what you have
access to is essentially what you can
buy which is sort of in this box here
the available feasible hardware design
space for systems for artificial
intelligence or machine learning or
almost any other application is vast ok
and what you're getting is people a
building you know cloud TP use or
something else these little point
solutions which are optimized for
particular kinds of workloads where some
deep learning or something like that
around here they do this for a very good
reason these things really work well ok
but if you're a researcher and you want
to explore this space you're stuck in
this box this box is clearly not where
the interesting action is so at a
university what can you do about this
problem what can you do to sort of
explore more of this space that perhaps
companies are not exploring because they
have particular commercial imperatives
there are particular time frames and
horizons beyond which it is not easy to
justify business wise to look if your
university perhaps we should be taking a
broader view longer term view that's why
they that's why the the companies tend
to fund us but we don't have any access
to the hardware ok so what do we do
ok and and I'm very lucky to be at ETH
in Zurich it's a great place one of the
great things about it is that companies
like to talk to us a lot and we don't
like dealing with companies and so the
big challenge the first big challenge
that you have as a systems researcher
trying to do some work in this area is
for
all you need to get hold of some
hardware ok get try and understand what
some of this hardware actually looks
like so this is where you hit the first
problem simply getting hold of some of
the hardware this is the version 1 of
the cloud TPU just purely did inference
inside Google it's very unlikely that
any of us will ever get our hands on one
of these unless we happen to work in
Google ok alright and there's a good
reason for that right this is not Google
being mean they're doing this for very
very sensible reasons right typically
these pieces of hardware are developed
Tiffany data center pieces of hardware
developed by something as a service
companies for their own internal use
right there is very little value to them
in enlarging the ecosystem of users of
this hard work directly particularly
when that hardware is accessible as a
cloud service anyway okay so the very
little point in google saying you know
oh here's here have some cloud GPUs do
interesting things with them because
anyone wants to actually run inference
on version one of the cloud GP you can
do it by renting the virtual machines
from Google and using it right there's
very little value in doing that and
there's also a subsea value in keeping
some of the hardware smarts in this
proprietary right you couldn't program
this with tensorflow but you don't need
to know anything more about that because
that's valuable intellectual property
for the company or at least the legal
department probably think so but also
there's a wall concerning reasons why
Google would not want to do this right
they don't want to have to support an
ASIC that Asics probably built on a
fairly aggressive process or at least
it's pushing the envelope it may not be
thoroughly tested he works well enough
for Google and that's what they want and
that's good enough they don't want to
actually have to pay for support they
don't want to have to actually deal with
other people getting strange results out
of these pieces of hardware that Google
themselves can prevent happening because
they actually control the entire
execution platform so it's really it's a
huge extra effort for Google to let
anybody else use a cloud GPU it really
isn't economic so it's unlikely even at
universities you're gonna be able to get
one of these things and it's not I'm not
complaining right I can see why this
happens ok
somehow though occasionally universities
some universities we're fortunate enough
to be one of them can get hold of some
pieces of hardware so for example this
is the version one of the Microsoft
catapult board okay which is very
interesting idea of being able to put an
FPGA on the data path between server and
the network and use it universally and
since on a PCI bus and whatever it's a
it's a very interesting thing this has
evolved gone through several more you
know revisions it's deployed widely
inside being an azure the challenge of
getting one of these things is figuring
out how it works once it's arrived so
actually most very very kindly donated a
bunch of version one of this because
we're doing a lot of work with FPGAs
accelerating big data workloads and
machine learning on a few days so a box
of these arrived at my colleagues office
one day with a you know very nice note
from from Microsoft saying you know here
they are and no documentation we
eventually did get some documentation in
the case of the of these boards but
other piece of hardware do arrive with
very little documentation and that's
probably because the companies often
don't have this documentation they built
this the hardware designers are sitting
next to the programmers why would you
need documentation it just takes time
and time to market is critical the
documentation falls by the wayside okay
and in some cases the lawyers really
don't want you to release the
documentation you can lend people the
hardware but don't give them the
documentation because the documentation
says things and that has written
snapmare have statements written down
that could get the company into trouble
okay so once you've got the hardware if
you're a research early university doing
something with the hardware is stymied
by need the documentation but the big
big big big problem right
like for example we've got a bunch of
catapults we eventually did get the
documentation they're very cool we did
some work with them but the big big big
problem with almost all of this hardware
from an academic perspective is the big
decisions have been made it's been
designed for a particular kind of
workload particularly use in mind okay
it is cost optimized right it is
designed to be deployed commercially
it's designed to provide the best return
on investment possible at in volume and
so there's a lot of cost-saving
specializations both in the hardware and
in the drivers it's range of you know
testing but also design is quite narrow
okay
and so you're gonna spend a lot of time
finding bugs in the hardware that are
not bugs from the company's perspective
because you're trying to do something
with the hardware that was never
intended by the company in the first
place or you're doing research on Rails
you're doing research into what the
hardware designer thought you should be
doing with the hardware anyway in that
case the people who are using this
hardware commercially are way ahead of
you
and so your research value may be
problematic even fairly general pieces
of purpose pieces of hardware this is an
intel part you can buy this this is a
single package with a skylake modified
skylake processor on it and an FPGA very
closely coupled to it and you'll see
this is quite close to what it is that
we're interested in building this is
Intel's view of what you should be using
to experiment with FP J's and this is
great it's very cool thing except for us
this FPGA here is a long way from the
rest of the system Intel's model is the
FPGA is something that helps the
processor do what the processor was
doing anyway and so you're sort of
you're restricting the model again quite
a lot by what Intel's view is of what
you can do this is a very cool part you
can buy this it's a product we had some
until very kinda gave us some early
access to this hardware but it remains
you know limited right there's certain
things that we might want to do that are
very hard to do on this kind of system
so we've talked about this a lot because
we've had access to a lot of custom
hardware at ETH and we've we've dealt
with we've worked through a lot of these
problems and so we we found ourselves
thinking this way what if we actually
got hold of a hardware platform that was
not optimized for running a commercial
workload it was actually optimized for
exploration it was optimized for
research what would it mean to build a
computer for research people he used to
do this back in the 70s they have not
done it recently okay it's optimized for
exploring the design space of hardware
and the implications of that design
space to software okay so it's not
designed to maximize performance per
watt or unit cost it can be more
expensive right but it should be over
right it should be as flexible as
possible much more than you could ever
commercially justify - you're selling
this to people you know in business
maybe these days you know you want you
don't just want just one of these as
well you wanted as a building block for
building bigger things so what if we had
a research platform that actually
allowed us to massively explore the the
hardware design space and build our own
very complex machines that were really
not constrained by the custom hardware
people are already building for their
own particular commercial needs could we
do this right and of course you know we
said you know our university we can't
build computers you know even ETH which
has a long tradition of building
computers at Niklaus Viet built a whole
series of computers in eth with
interesting kind of features but its
universities have typically not done
this at scale right they've done it in
the electrical engineering department
but then build the kind of computers
you'd actually want to use to do real
computer science whenever you think
about doing it you know you think well
you know we're limited to some extent by
our imagination here is what our
imagination came up with when we were
discussing this mythical computer that
would actually help us with our research
it's not doesn't do everything it has
its limitations has its compromises but
it was based on the kind of research we
were doing and the obstacles we were
hitting right where we got into trouble
all we'd like is a server a proper
realistic server decent memory decent
network bandwidth decent peripherals you
know proper cause right processor kind
of processor that you might actually
have in a datacenter and what we want is
very close to that
ideally connected by some very low-level
protocol right the biggest FPGA we can
find something is def PJ we can find
but I'm the biggest in the fastest FPGA
we can find it okay and this FPGA should
have a lot of memory itself and a lot of
network bandwidth in fact all the
network bandwidth you can stick on this
Fe J plus you know some peripherals and
things if we want it okay this is a
realistic today's computing platform
this allows us to explore the hardware
design space
having the two together gives us a very
powerful platform for exploring things
this is what we thought we wanted based
on our research you know I colleague
cast our vote on Lonzo and I have been
doing a lot of working FPGA is operating
systems databases these kinds of things
wouldn't it be great if we had one of
these things we asked first people if
they would build it for us
various companies if they build it for
us and people said well you know this is
really expensive and there's really no
market for this so we thought well maybe
we could actually build it ourselves and
one of the things that has driven this
diversity of hardware is also but you
made it quite easy to build hardware
it's not easy but it's easier than it
was in this sort of post PC era
we're actually entering a phase where
it's becoming reasonable to think about
building quite complicated pieces of
hardware even on a universities kind of
budget rigidly we have a quite a nice
budget but it's still an academic budget
we did not want to rely on standards
okay so other things you'll notice in
this this diagram here is that I talked
about this sort of cache coherent
interface here there are some standards
out for this in our opinion they're all
problematic we don't like any of them
from a research perspective there might
make sense commercially in the short
term but in particular we did not want
PCI Express if you want if you're
prepared to accept PCI Express as the
way of connecting these two parts of the
system you're in good shape you can go
out and buy cards from Xilinx or from
our terror or so that'll do this stuff
we did not want that and there's plenty
of reasons why we had you know P so
Express is good for what it did it gets
in the way for a lot of the work that
we're doing right so what can we build
one of these could we actually actually
build a computer that did this job
surprisingly we actually thought we
could we can use it for two things right
the design I've shown you is good for
emulating possible new platform designs
right we can use that FPGA to make it
look like all kinds of things particular
we can use it to make it look like a
catapult or look like an Amazon f1
instance or look like you know other
things that are done with FPGA is and we
can even do little toy versions of TP
use and things on there not as fast as
an ASIC but nevertheless we can try
things out but actually perhaps this is
actually quite a good platform anyways
purpose hey that fpj gives you huge
flexibility so it's an interesting
question ok and we managed to get hold
of some hardware we cobbled together
some hardware that particular company
called caveum gave us this is an
evaluation board for their version one
of their 48 core 64-bit ARM processor ok
what's cool about this board is that
this processor is a dual socket part
that's it has external cache coherence
but this board has only one socket and
it has three connectors and that
actually carry the cache coherency
traffic onto another board so you
basically they gave this out to OEMs and
if you want to prototype a dual socket
system you just plug two of these boards
together turn it on it boots up in a two
socket system we didn't do that what we
did was to plug these connectors here
into an FPGA board which we also got
from Xilinx with the biggest FPGA we
could find which is the exceed 9p at the
time this is the one that's used in
Hamden f1 and by plugging these things
together we could actually try and
implement something that caused us to
talk to the caveum cache coherency
protocol and caveum were very very
helpful at telling us how this stuff
worked and giving us access to a lot of
information okay and so we actually
built it it looks she looks like this
this is my postdocs office here's the
caveum board here are these three eye
watering lis expensive cables that carry
cache coherence onto this board which we
built ourselves which is really just an
adapter board that plugs into zai Lynx's
evaluation board over here okay and this
machine is the initial version of
something we call ends in your boots
it runs Linux but also runs barrel fish
the last operating system we built in
the group and they're actually two of
these you can see there the one in the
background there but this next picture
for this to work on okay this next
picture shows you actually have two of
these systems together and this is what
we've been basically working on for the
last year so it's building these things
together now this is a big clunky
machine I said we didn't need to be cost
optimized or power or anything but I
want you know if I'm gonna have a
research platform like this you know III
2 of these is fine but I want a hundred
of these in Iraq and we're not going to
be able to deal with a hundred of the
we actually want is to shrink all of
this stuff down to a single board and
actually put a lot more stuff on it okay
that's actually what we're doing right
now actually in the process of doing
that right now and this is the design of
the board that we actually want and we
should get prototypes of this back in
about five weeks from manufacture
whereupon we have to get all the
software working we have a very short
amount of space at the time to get the
software working but this is this is the
board that we think represents the right
compromise between what we can build
what we really want to explore that huge
hardware design space we've got four
hundred gigabits of network bandwidth
over here 16 25 gig sewer lines you can
configure these as Ethernet and whatever
we've got half a terabyte of memory here
it's not gonna be enough
but it's good right half a terabyte of
DRAM on the FPGA is fine 128 gigabytes
is pretty much all the the memory this
Thunder axe will take so fully fully
stuffing this 40 to 40 gig Ethernet
interfaces is fully utilizing all the
ethernet hardware on here basically
everything is maxed out this is the
biggest thing we can fit on one board
deliberately so maximum
reconfigurability maximum flexibility we
don't care about unit cost turns out
unit cost isn't so bad
it's totally dominated by derail so
everything else is kind of lost in the
noise apart from this and Xilinx have
been very very helpful and generous with
us with these chips but then you've got
you know PCI Express you can plug your
GPU in here if you really want to nvme
nvme piso express all the usual stuff
but the really key thing is this very
close coupling here right we can send
data onto custom hardware and here back
to the processor extremely fast an
extremely low level without having to go
through any of these sort of buses or
anything like that
as I said this surprised to my surprise
because I'm not a hardware person first
time I've done this we're actually very
close to having one of these things
actually built we're having 15 of these
things actually built which is the first
production run this is actually what its
gonna look like this is well sent but
sent back by the design house who we
contracted to build this is this pretty
cool this is a render
what the board's going to look like for
me is the sort of you know software
person it's really cool to be able to
play with these things this this thing
here is the the FPGA this is the caveum
processor got all the usual connectors
here USB SATA and stuff ah said designed
for flexibility and also designed for
reliability rather than price so we cut
corners so for example these connectors
here actually fly over connectors for
very high speed signals it makes the
board easier design makes it easier more
likely to work the next time less
worried about signal integrity all this
kind of stuff here's all the all the
network interfaces are on the back here
two different PCI slots one for each
side most of all I showed on the
previous diagram you can sort of
recognize on this board I thought this
is really cool I've never ever built
Hardware before and to my surprise at a
university I could actually get this
stuff done hopefully it'll work it
arrives pretty soon now we obviously
don't want to hang on to this just for
ourselves we'll keep the first 15
assuming they actually work but the goal
here really is that this is this is is
really how we change how the system's
community the operating systems
community the database community and
their systems for machine learning
community can actually work we've talked
to lots of people who think that this
would be very useful to them may be
useful to you our goal is to build a lot
of this do these things and seed them
out to where the universities this is a
an attempt to shift the research agenda
into something that is more exciting but
also more relevant in the longer term
and to get operating systems research
and other kinds of systems research out
of this sort of box that it's got a
little bit tied into so there's
precedents for this you know net fpga
you may be familiar with planetlab
system i built a while ago at Intel DP
DK even BSD our ideas of the research
community building artifacts that helped
them then do their research this is kind
of one of those things and so that's
really what I wanted to sort of talk
about hopefully in the next few months
we'll have the first ones back and then
you know we'll start talking to other
people who have already expressed an
interest in having them and start
building a community around this kind of
platform rather than commodity pcs as a
way of doing research lots of people
have been involved in this it's quite a
big team and we
tons of help from caveum and Xilinx
they've been really really nice to us
these are the current people on the team
it's probably going to change next week
as well we'll get some more people on
board and with that I'm done now so the
summary here is that common
off-the-shelf hardware even GPUs to some
extent these days they're not
necessarily realistic for this kind of
work in the future if you really want to
be out there in the future you need to
get ahead of people building custom
hardware and this I think is our best
bet for getting ahead of the custom
hardware people because the custom
hardware people will already have made a
load of decisions that will restrict the
kind of exploration that we can do and
so hopefully in a few years time a
significant chunk of the people will
actually have access to platforms like
this or something like it and we can
actually explore this design space it's
pretty cool it's a pretty exciting way
of the rethinking system software and
the light of this kind of reconfigurable
Hardware so that I am done thank you for
listening I'm happy to take questions
[Applause]
your team that this board should come
see the light of the day very soon
just one question do you want to do you
have any donating neither we can't
donate it we're not a charity we're not
interested necessarily in making a huge
amount of money out of it that may just
be me I have a slide you said I've died
I've worked for startups and I I
survived are our goal at the moment is
to make this available to the research
community essentially at cost okay so
our sort of template is net FPGA right
which was done about five six years ago
it's a PCI NIC essentially without fpga
on it what they did was they set up a
non-profit company is essentially got
the range for the manufacturer
distribution of these things at cost
we've been talking as eiling's
the big unknown about the cost of it is
the cost of that huge FPGA and Xilinx
are very interested in
providing that to whoever we get to
build these in volume academic pricing
or say to two kinds of pricing one for
academics one for companies that might
want to use it we have had interest from
companies in actually acquiring a few of
these things at even Microsoft there's a
co-ed Microsoft Research she wants to
yes first challenges the boards are not
available I'm glad that your team is
taking care of their children second
challenge told that the documentation
for the board is also not here
I hope somebody in your team is taking
care of that hazard documentation for
this for our our hope is to actually
well first of all provide a lot of
documentation a lot of useful example
software and everything but also to make
as much of the design open as possible
there are bits of that design that we're
in negotiation with companies to
actually talk about even if we even if
we can't talk about some bits of it we
think we can wrap those up into the FPGA
shell and then still without impeding
the flexibility of the rest of platform
so the goal is to make this absolutely
as open as possible yes this is an
academic thing open-source is good more
information allows people to do more
stuff so absolutely outside that's our
goal okay I'm sorry very good belong to
me Viktor - yeah so I think this is
great I actually do I think gone so many
of these sort of things in the past but
I have a bunch of questions I'll reserve
them for later with you but I want to
ask you here in public what's what are
you burning to do with this board right
now what are we burning yes so what I
mean by that so many of these so you
know I also have some experience doing
things like this in the past and and so
there's a sort of difference between
what gets adopted and what
the street runs with versus what papers
get written by in terms of the research
so is there something that is well other
things that we can't do right so I so I
have about you know in back up here I
have about fifteen different slides each
of which has a different research
project we want to try out on this I
didn't run didn't run through the
product it's a time but because many of
them are not to do with machine learning
but we have a whole list of different
applications we'd like to use this for
and use it in various different ways you
can view the FPGA as a gatekeeper you
can view it as a smart NIC as a
monitoring system as an accelerator as a
memory controller there's all kinds of
different things we have lots of ideas
there it is a compromise you know but it
but it's given us it gives us way more
flexibility that we can get with any
other platform we could buy from that
perspective and so before we started we
had a whole load of ideas for doing this
but there's another benefit to actually
going through this process which is one
of the reasons that I'm still smiling
after all this stuff which is that we
never built a computer before we've
never known you know this is a you know
it's an eighteen layer AIT export this
is a big deal it's been really an
interesting experience learning about
this I've had a superb postdoc who's
really into formal methods os design and
hardware and he's been doing a lot of
the heavy lifting on the hardware side
of this stuff so we've learned a huge
amount about how modern computers work
which you don't tend to learn we don't
teach and it could be in a university
curriculum and we could not not good
about teaching curriculum that itself
has generated a whole lot of other ideas
so it's been a very generative project
even if it never works we you know we
have come up with so many interesting
questions because of the different
perspective we have gained on computer
hardware as a result of doing it so
that's an additional benefit I mean
these are hard to quantify but
fortunately at a university there's less
pressure on
quantify these things so it's yeah III
would say it's been it's been worth all
the effort so far um will it have been
all the way they have but so far if we
never get it working
maybe not but yeah it's close it's been
a journey with the software into pieces
for such a many many thoughts we don't
think one size fits all because there
are so many different researchers cases
I mean this question of whether you you
know in the system that you're
evaluating whether you make the FPGA
visible or you try to forget about the
FPGA X it's emulating a different piece
of hardware and stuff so all of those
will really change how the software
works into in the specific case where
the FPGA is part of the application
right it's actually doing functioning
like an accelerator or a smart Nick the
right way to do that software interface
is either one of the several of the
research projects we want to do at
different levels right so there's how do
I interact with an accelerator what is
the kind of accelerator design we want
if you talk to operating systems people
about the in the software interface to
hardware you know they can happily ramp
for ages about how broken this is and
how hardware designers don't understand
what it's thinking it means to program
these things but if you ask us what it
should look like we go kind of quiet
because we tend to lack the language to
talk about the rights or the hardware
software interface ourselves one of my
goals in doing this is to get a better
understanding of that so I can actually
say what the right hardware software
interface is from an operating systems
perspective and try to encode some of
those rules ultimately because I've also
found myself drifting into formal
methods recently what I'd like is to
build a writer specification of the
software and an interface to a piece of
hardware that is emulated on FPGA in its
in in some formal language and have it
generate both the driver
and our log for the hardware at the same
time and then I can build into that
compiler a lot of the tacit knowledge
that operating systems people have about
the right way to talk to hardware you
know enough asynchrony self
virtualization protection you know
access control that sort of stuff we can
actually put into the compiler as a way
of encoding what we what we've learned
to talk about in the process of doing
this but don't know these are these are
really open questions and and I think
they're important ones okay code that
the current state of the art is very I
don't and I think we can do a lot better
as scientist
[Applause]